[Music]
take a bite of my beautiful world Kobe
is I don't even know how to put it in
worried but I believe Kobe is like the
Sun and LA desperately needed the reason
la loves kalbi because Kobe has the LA
spirit lo cocky and on I mean confident
he connected himself to this city he
connects himself to that energy of like
we're not just living in the city we are
this city he's the patron saint of
basketball that's what he is
I think when a incident with Kobe and
the people on the on board and
helicopter how it affected the world was
I think at first it was a tragic as the
days went on and I was like how can I
honor a guy who if you had any
basketball conversation he was always in
you know all those pictures and of him
just started popping up all over the
social media all over the all over the
news
there it is I need to take those photos
and try to recreate them because I
wanted to show the Mamba mentality
within and I want to match these iconic
pictures with great iconic people man I
chose Snoop Ice Cube and O'Shea common
hello folks
Amanda seals and Chadwick Boseman that's
the superhero and everyone hello folks
so what we doing is like taking the
iconic photos of Kobe
we gotta kind of recreate him the one
for you is that because he's a
forward-thinking
that's a joke yeah for y'all it's likely
you schooling him on game I like them so
it's like he's the superhero like right
there it is like he just won and the
exorbitant all of that like the Mamba
mentality is always about something
making it move being clever and
inventive and trying to create something
and being on there on the edge Sony the
Mamba mentality is focus work ethic and
Drive
amanda is the intensity of Kobe she goes
to a lot of gamuts of emotions right in
front of you and that's what we saw with
Kobe for me to mama mentality it's
unstoppable unstoppable force that that
you have inside of you that whatever
your vision and passion is is nothing
that could stop it because you believe
in it so much as a young player you know
Kobe had a chip on his shoulder he he
was ferocious his fuel was just to be
the best and what he would talk to you
know his fans and those listening about
is to be the best at whatever your field
is so about the Mamba man
mama-mama mentality 24 8 most people do
it 24/7
he does it 24 8 that's just how life is
[Music]
man that's this one I picked that
picture for myself man and um that was
the most um
that was the most difficult
now's the most difficult because of his
daughter I have three I know what I do
for them families first like that's
first regardless of everything else so
that's what I admired about it
[Music]
it's Kolb's right here we got these last
words they're like what's the last word
you were saying we love you all and and
we will continue to keep your energy and
your spirit alive and all that we do
your life is meant so much to so many
people I can't even put it into words
how much cuz I didn't even know I didn't
know how much eat me I knew I loved Kobe
but I didn't know I loved you as much as
I did
oh man I love you Kobe just for being
yourself you know your spirit is in all
of us man and we're gonna continue to
have that same mentality thank you for
for building up so many of us to have a
mentality to be our best and wherever
you are shoot my last words to Vulcan in
save me a spot up top I see y'all when I
get there
[Music]